[Music]
thank you
hi dear friends we're so delighted that
you decided to join us today for a
program I'd like to know
uh as you probably many of you know this
is a question and answer program where
uh the watching audience sends us the
questions we do the research and if
there's an answer we try to find it and
we answer it here on the screen so thank
you so much for joining us and let me
give you the address of the place where
you can send your questions if you
desire to do so it's TV at some tv.org
you'll see it on the screen TV at some
tv.org and I'm in the company of Pastor
Daniel Miranda who is very much involved
here at sequence unsealed even though he
has two full-time jobs now well I guess
secrets on sale wouldn't be a full-time
job but uh he helps us a lot here with
questions and answers with sermons
symposiums and so many different things
we appreciate you being willing to come
to do these programs I'd like to know in
English and Spanish thank you so much
for being here thank you Pastor board
I'm so happy to be here as we often say
this is one of our favorite programs and
we love interacting with you receiving
your questions so thank you for sending
those questions and thank you for the
invitation possible okay praise the Lord
would you have a word of prayer to ask
the Lord to bless the program today
please absolutely my pleasure let's pray
uh dear heavenly father we're trying
Heaven we're so thankful dear Lord for
the opportunity to study your word we
thank you dear Lord because we know that
there is people watching us who are
in love with scripture they want to
learn more about you and your word and
we pray Lord that you may guide us we
place ourselves in your hands so that we
may be instruments to lead people to the
light of scriptures in the name of Jesus
we pray amen amen well I understand that
we have several questions as we begin on
the issue of Music in the church so what
is the person asking I guess there's
several questions that is correct we
have several questions in regards to
music and church worship
so the first question comes from Brian
moisigua I think this is from
Brian from Spokane Washington
and this is the question is there a
musical genre not necessarily lyrics but
a style of music that would be
considered ungodly does the bible
provide Counsel on this
I've heard some pastors discourage the
use of drums in the century is this
biblical
now the next question is very related is
even more complete this is actually this
is the same guy Brian
but now he adds more we got this
question later and we put it together
so he says I've heard some ministers
discouraged the use of drums in the
sanctuary they are not necessarily
against the idea of using drums per se
but the argument against the use of
drums is that the more we allow its
usage in the sanctuary the more we are
in danger of encouraging a form of
worship that is not Christ centered but
self-centered they say that drums stir
up certain emotions and physical
excitement in our body that is only
based on feeding the carnal mind is
there any biblical Counsel on this and
the last question there are three
questions in one
he quotes Psalm 149 verse 3.
that says let them Praise His Name with
dancing making Melody to him with
tambourine and lyrics liar
and some 150 verse 4 it says praise him
with tambourine and dance praise him
with strings and pipe
so this last question has to do with the
word bands what does it mean what does
it mean to dance in the Bible
okay well it's a multiple question
um that we have here let's deal first of
all with the issue of drums okay
and you know
I don't think except for maybe the
electric guitar which is a synthesizer
you know it's not really an instrument
as such because it makes all kinds of
distorted sounds but
um the problem is not the instrument
yeah the problem is the way in which the
instrument is used is correct uh you
know you can use snare drums with a
symphony orchestra and it's perfectly
proper
but the problem is that the way that
drums are used in many churches today is
that it is a consistent syncopation and
consistent Rhythm uh that that does what
this person mentions in the question and
that is that it appeals to the lower
nature
um
are there certain genres of music that
should not be used in the church I
believe that there are yes
um you know music that was prepared for
the world
like jazz jazz is for New Orleans for
the nightclubs and for the bars music
such as reggaeton yes uh you know music
such as salsa heavy metal Rock heavy
metal rock all of this music is prepared
uh for the world
and it actually takes our thoughts away
from the Lord uh rather than drawing us
closer to the Lord correct
and to support what you're saying in
Daniel chapter 3 we find a good example
in that uh we remembered the story of
the bucat nether's image when he
commanded all to come and worship the
image now he used music
to draw the attention of the people to
the image to prepare their senses
what is interesting here is that in the
list of instruments that are used there
are some instruments that were used also
for worship right so your point is is on
point when you say that it's not so much
about the instrument is about how we use
it so here in Daniel chapter 3 verse 7
the bible says
soil at that time when all the people
heard the sound of the horn flute flutes
and horns were used in the in the Hebrew
Sanctuary for the music harp the liar
and Symphony with all kinds of music all
the people Nations and languages fell
down and worshiped the golden image
which Nebuchadnezzar had set up so here
he takes some instruments that in and of
themselves are not bad but he uses them
and I imagine I don't know what kind of
music they play but I imagine it was
sensual it was like it was intended to
be numb the senses of the people so that
they could be led to this Pagan worship
of the image so the music was very
related with worship right here you know
I play the trumpet okay and from the
same trumpet
I can play jazz yeah like you're in New
Orleans or I can play
uh how great thou art from the same
instrument
one will lead you to kind of you know
move your body and and I I say this and
some people don't like the illustration
but I say any music that moves you from
the neck up is good music
that moves you from the neck down
you need to wonder whether it's good
music because you know people these days
want an emotional religion yes they
don't want an intellectual religion you
know where you have to think
and you have to work through Bible
passages to understand them you know
people want to go to church to have an
excitement yes the same thing that
happened in the 1900 Indiana the holy
flesh movement and the pr the problem
with the music at the Indiana camp
meeting I mean it was tame in comparison
with some of the music Styles see I mean
Ellen White described it as a great big
bass drum uh you know and they actually
used hymns that appear in our Hymnal
today but she said that the music had
the purpose Satan used it with the
intention of making of non-effect the
Three Angels message she repeats that
time again again yes in other words
worship should appeal to the intellect
and not only to the emotions amen amen
because emotions change yes but what you
learn you know what you settle in your
brain uh and it's not based on emotion
that endures
so worship is an intelligent exercise
and not only an emotional exercise and
now you know to bring some balance and I
bring it up is not in the question but I
believe this is why being the minds of
some who are listening to us at this
time
what about culture
because there has been discussions in
our church and all over the world we
hear this often that for example people
from Africa certain parts of Africa they
have certain styles of people from
Brazil and from South America the Andes
for example when I go to Peru Bolivia
they have this beautiful music that they
they play our hymns but with flute with
um
uh with uh different string instruments
that they use in the ending music right
so
what is the place of cultural Styles in
the in in music Christian music and what
are the limits
the bottom line is if the cultural
Styles follow the principles of good
music good worship music
use it that's the balance yeah you know
that's that's where the balance is
culture itself
is not bad or good it's whether what
culture practices is in harmony with
Biblical principles exactly and uh and
once again the issue you know one of one
problem that there is is that music in
many churches has overshadowed the
message exactly and I'll give you an
example I was invited to preach in a
certain church here in the central
California Conference many years ago
and uh I line up and I sat there from 11
o'clock to 12 o'clock
and it was a praise time at 12 o'clock
the pastor came and whispered in my ear
he said pastor you know time is just
about up you have 15 minutes to present
your sermon well come on an hour for
praise music and 15 minutes for the
sermon which is going to edify your mind
you know I felt that that was out of
place because Adventist Adventist
worship Services have always centered on
the message yes and not the emotions
that go with the message of course there
are there should be emotion of course in
worship but it should not over uh over
Bear Yes uh the message that is Central
to the worship service amen so there is
a there is a book that I was I just
found it
here there is a compilation by NY that
is called music it's role qualities and
influence yeah it's a good compilation
that we highly encourage you to read
and uh there is there is chapter five of
this book I believe
um she touches on the place of secular
Styles in our worship service so for
example she tells the story of when she
was traveling on that she was on a boat
trip and and there were certain
classical musicians playing and and that
wasn't necessarily a worship worship
music but it was a good music and she
says that how much she enjoyed it yeah
so um so that's what we're talking about
now I think our previous question in
regards to culture
that leads us to the next question that
has to do with dancing
because definitely we find some
reference and Illusions in the Old
Testament to a certain dance that was
accompanied with music but in none of
those passages is it dealing with a
worship service they're dealing with
festivities yes that that were in Israel
but there's no place where you find
dancing within the confines of the
sanctuary or of the Temple
and now how would you understand because
some who are listening here might might
think that well then we can dance
whenever we are not at church yeah the
dance that the Bible mentions is more an
expression of Joy than anything else yes
and it's not dancing with someone
it's it's dancing like David did yeah
some people use the example of David to
justify dancing he said well David
danced it's amazing how we we try to
find in the Bible uh stories that
support what we want to do but with
David clearly it was a specific
historical circumstance yes it was
jumping for joy because the ark was
returning to Jerusalem so you know to
use the example of David for romantic
dancing of a man and a woman real close
together is is totally out of out of uh
out of whack yes I learned my comments
in the book uh the
paychecks and Prophets commenting on on
when David dance and Mikhail saw him and
she was a shame of what he was doing she
says that the dance of David is not like
the dance that we practice today that
leads to licentiousness and all those
sinful practices right it was just an
expression of joy
that he had because the ark had been
brought up right and brought back to
Jerusalem so it doesn't have anything to
do with the current uh dance that we
have today in bars or disco attacks and
all that right and he was not commanded
to dance
and the Bible has many stories
that we can't use to justify things that
we want to do just because the Bible
mentions about something that somebody
did doesn't mean that it's okay for us
to do it you know the fact that David
David danced for Joy uh you know does
that mean that God is commanding us to
dance whenever we're filled with joy not
necessarily not necessarily yes
so anyway I have some principles here of
music that Ellen White presents yes
please I'm not going to read the
accompanying statements if somebody
would like to have these I have a whole
document that I wrote on the issue of
worship music but uh in church music The
Melody should predominate over the
harmony
but today it's mostly the harmony yes
that is emphasized uh furthermore
music is subliminal
in the sense that it bypasses a rational
area of the brain you know it goes
directly to our emotional system
um Ellen White warns against vain
repetition
she also speaks about music not having
an extremely high volume
uh she also says that it should follow
the rhythm of the body
the the heart does not have a syncopated
beat it's
um
so syncopation uh you know like for
example Onward Christian the strong beat
is the first and the second is soft and
the third is strong syncopation is just
the opposite and so it goes against the
the natural Rhythm of the body uh and
then Ellen White says you're not
supposed to distort your voice you're
supposed to sing the notes clearly the
way they are and it should not focus its
attention on the artist
and furthermore it should not
necessarily be used because it makes us
feel good
uh because but because it's in harmony
with Biblical and spiritual prophecy
principles amen
I want to correct myself thank you for
sharing that possible the book The
chapter I was mentioning I said chapter
five but it's not chapter five it's
chapter seven of this book which is
entitled secular music and I just want
to read one quote
the subtitle is under that chapter
qualities of acceptable secular music
yeah interesting for about an hour the
fog did not lift and the sun did not
penetrate then the musicians
are on the ship
who were to leave the boat at this place
entertain the impatient Messengers with
music well selected and well rendered it
did not jar upon the senses as the
previous evening but was soft and really
grateful to the census because it was
Musical
so it wasn't necessarily a worship time
here for music but she makes a
difference it didn't jar upon the senses
like the previous evening but this one
was soft and was musical right I enjoy
classical music there's some
masterpieces you know of secular
classical music but it follows the
principles of good music exactly and so
you know this is a really interesting
question a very important question I've
done a lot of
writing on the issue of music I have a
long write up on the Indiana camp
meeting if people are interested they
can contact us and and I'll be glad to
share that with them I also have some of
the things that with the Ellen White
backing of the principles that I
mentioned just a few minutes ago sure
okay so we have a
other
set of questions in regards to the same
issue which is church worship
and this question comes from iww
and the question says I'd like to know
can we sing praise to the Lord with
tambourines which I think we have
already answered it depends on how we
use them
and then they see Menace
she says hello Passover is it okay to
play classical music in the church also
it is okay to have music recitals in the
church playing classical music and
Christmas music
I appreciate you taking time to read and
answering my questions
well there's classical music that
follows the principles of good music but
if we're having a sacred worship service
I think we should use Sacred Music
correct you know it's like handle handle
prepared or composed Messiah lots of
secular music yeah
but he also composed Messiah so it's
best I think to use sacred in a sacred
environment and secular in a secular
environment you know you have to the
Bible says that you need to you need to
keep the sacred and the secular separate
yes one from the other
and of course when we talk about secular
we're talking about Good secular music
good secular music exactly of course not
um as some some that I have heard
especially in in Central and South
America that they all agree that worship
music worship music in the church should
be solemn sacred but once you are
outside of the church service
then you are not constrained by those
limits and you can listen to any secular
music yeah and that's that's that's
another extreme the problem with that
is that we use the argument that in
order to retain the youth in the church
we have to give them the music that they
list listen away from church so when you
become accustomed to that exciting music
if you please that appeals to emotions
to the gut you know and it makes you
move and everything once you get used to
that music it becomes like a
psychological drug and you come to
church and somebody plays the piano and
you're singing to him they say boring
yes because because they've accustomed
their spiritual palette to the music of
the world and they want to import it
into the church yes so that's the danger
that is the danger exactly
so we have
we have six minutes five minutes left
maybe we can deal with this question on
uh SDA and politics by Neville
slim way
um there are two questions in one
without regard to exceptions what is the
recommended diet for Seventh-day
Adventist Church members are waiting an
enactment of the Sunday law and
translation
shoot Seventh-Day Adventists participate
in their country's political Affairs
especially in voting as is it erroneous
for an Adventist not to vote and what is
penal substitution and is it biblical
you know by penal substitution if we can
start with that one first
I think that it's referring to Christ
taking our punishment upon himself I'm
not sure what the person who is asking
the question means by penal substitution
but you know the Jesus Took the penalty
he substituted for me if that's what it
means well the Bible teaches penal
substitution because it says that you
know he hung on the tree he was cursed
he suffers a curse so that the blessing
of Abraham can come upon us he who knew
no sin was made to be sin for us correct
so the Bible clearly teaches penal
substitution in that sense I don't know
if you can read between the lines if you
mean something else no I think I am in
line with you that's what I can think of
unless he has another idea in mind okay
uh so um without regards to exceptions
what is the recommended diet for Seventh
Adventist Church members awaiting an
enactment of the Sunday law and
translation
well we have plenty on Council on this
the Bible and the spirit of Prophecy is
even more detail that God's desire for
us is to go back to the original diet of
course in our context
and our fallen
context of 6 000 years of sin when our
our bodies are weakened and I emphasize
that because some people read going back
to the original diet and they think okay
then we need to eat Bean to raw food
because
[Music]
their food and that has some benefits
but I should not impose it on other
people right but but that's the ideal
diet as far as possible
yeah well the Bible tells us what the
ideal diet is there you go it says in
Genesis 1 29 and God said see I have
given you every herb that yields seed
which is on the face of all the Earth
and every tree whose fruit yields seed
to you it shall be for food and we have
the example of Daniel and his friends
yes you know they had uh they had a
vegetarian diet maybe vegan you know a
full vegan doesn't even use leather
products so you know we have to we have
to take the difference the word vegan
with a grain of salt yes but but it was
actually based on fruits and then after
sin vegetables fruits and herbs that
says herbs of the field and so can we
improve upon the diet that God
established no we can't now there are
some places like for example the eskimos
is non-existent so you have to be
practical and take it into account the
circumstances but here in the Western
World in Europe in the United States in
Australia all those places you know you
have access to fruits all different
kinds of fruit and you have access to
herbs and nuts and and nuts yeah so uh
it's not necessary to partake of things
that God did not create originally to be
partaken of exactly I agree with you
so how about thank you Pastor board how
about voting
is it okay for Adventists to vote
well ly tells us that we should not vote
for candidates that are going to
implement principles contrary to to you
know the principles that we hold of
religious freedom primarily when it
comes to the issue of religious liberty
she says you know we need to check out
and see if the candidate is 100 in favor
of religious liberty which would be the
First Amendment to the Constitution
um but of course Adventists should vote
but it doesn't mean that should that
they should be go going out to the
presidential rallies and you know with
placards and that have you know words on
them you know supporting any political
party but we should vote after doing
research yes uh regarding the candidates
to see if the candidate uh while he's in
office is going to commit sins that then
we would be guilty of for putting them
in office that's the council we've been
given and the Bible doesn't exclude
God's children from being involved in in
this kind of things even we have some
figures like Joseph and Daniel that
occupied some political positions but
there are some good people I would say
very few that launch for this political
positions and she says that when there
is a good candidate that it is our duty
to to vote as Citizens she has a quote I
can remember that even on the Sabbath
she encouraged in a specific
circumstance if we need to to to to to
to support right
well time does fly by folks we're almost
to the end of our program I want to take
the remaining seconds that we have left
to thank you for sending the questions
to us and to encourage you to send your
questions to us once again the address
is TV at some tv.org TV at some tv.org
thank you for joining us God bless you
hope to see you next time and I'd like
to know
[Music]
foreign